>> Okay Michael, what have we learned.
>> Well, we learned the definition for feature selection,
which was getting a subset of the features to feed
to some, I think we also talked about supervised training
algorithms, or learning algorithms after the selection has taken place.
>> Right.
>> We made a distinction between [NOISE] rapping and filtering.
>> Was that supposed to be filtering?
>> Yeah, I didn't know how the filtering sounds.
>> It sounded more like slurping.
>> Yeah, I'm not sure that my raping actually sounded like rapping either.
>> It didn't, but I wasn't going to say anything. So what else
did we learn? Besides, you like sound effects. So we learned about feature
selection, we defined that. We discussed
the difference between filtering methods for feature
selection and wrapping methods for feature
selection. What did we learn about them?
>> That wrapping is slow, but actually
seems like it solves the problem that matters.
>> Yeah. So let's call that slow but useful.
>> Is that useful in the sense that you defined it?
>> Yes. Mm Hm.
>> Boy these can be useful words. Filtering
is simpler, possibly faster, but maybe misses the point.
>> Probably faster, yeah, but ignores bias. Okay, so what else? Is that it?
>> Well so
we, and we specifically learned about the distinction
between features being useful versus them being relevant.
>> That's right. so, relevant things are things that give
you information about the classification problem, or the regression problem
that you care about. But useful, features are things that
help you to actually do the learning, given some specific algorithm.
>> Right. And you reminded what a Bayes optimal classifier
was. [LAUGH]. Which I guess I should have known already.
But somehow, I did not understand how it fit into this context.
>> The, the main power Bayes optimal classifiers is
that it is sort of the gold standard, it
is the ultimate that you could do if you
had everything and all the time in the world.
>> Could I say that relevance is
usefulness with regard to the Bayes optimal classifier?
>> Yes, actually you could, I like that. It is a special case [UNKNOWN].
>> Oh wait,
there's something else that you talk, that you talked about.
>> Yes.
>> Which was, strong and weak relevance.
>> Right.
>> And in a sense that relevant features
have a kind of kryptonite, in the sense
that you can make them not strong just
by putting a copy of them into this space.
>> Right. I like that, the kryptonite is copy. Well done.
That's because you're no longer indispensable. If I have a copy you.
>> That's right, you and now your
evil twin now resides in your parallel universe.
>> So what
do you think that means for us? Are
we, strongly relevant, weakly relevant or useless? [Laughs]
>> And those are your choices. [Laughs]. I am,
I'm going to say I am weakly relevant because I
think I correlate with truth, assuming the subset of
other people in the world is the empty set.
>> Hm. . Fair enough, fair enough. So then
by that definition, do I get to be weakly relevant?
>> You are atleast weakly relevant.
>> Very good.
Very good. But are we useful.
>> We're going to say yes. As far as our students know.
>> [LAUGH] Well I guess that's the way we will
find out ultimately is how well they do on the course.
>> It's true. It's in some sense completely in their hands.
>> Right. So in fact, this course is a
wrapper method over features and this is the first iteration.
>> Interesting.
>> Wow, that was deep. I feel like we should end on that.
>> I
do too.
>> Okay, well then I will see you
next time when we will talk about feature transformation.
>> Transformation.
>> Well done. Bye.
>> Bye.